videos a teenager made before killing
himself are now key evidence in the
manslaughter trial of his friend Conrad
Roy's videos offer a glimpse of the 18
year old struggles with depression
prosecutors say that Michelle Carter
bombarded Roy with texts and urged him
to take his life because she wanted
attention 48 hours of course wanted
Aaron Moriarty is following this trial
Erin good morning good morning
prosecutors introduced the videos into
evidence before resting their case
Thursday they show Conrad Roy speaking
candidly about his inner turmoil but
that's something that also could help
the defense Michele Carter's attorneys
argue that Roy was already suicidal long
before he met her this is Conrad Henry
roid the third reporting about social
anxiety at times Conrad Roy seemed
brimming with hope in his videos he was
have a job from the Boston Duck Tours to
Captain they're both right that's a huge
accomplishment but later his despair
came into focus
there's no good trash will never be
successful kids never learned in July
2014
Roy died inside this truck from carbon
monoxide poisoning as he was dying
prosecutors say he was on the phone with
Michelle Carter for 46 minutes days
before in numerous texts Carter then 17
offered Roy's suggestions on how to take
his own life and lectured him when he
wavered but I'm tired of you not taking
this seriously
like if you aren't really gonna do it
then stop pretending that you are one
message said another read hang yourself
jump off a building stab yourself I
don't know there's a lot of ways
Carter's lawyers say investigators
ignored text she sent trying to help him
I'm trying to do the best to dig you out
you're not aware of that are you no no
and you're not probably not aware that
he said I don't want to be dug out no
are you aware that he said he wanted to
kill himself the defense is expected to
blame Carter's Medicaid
for her odd behavior and argue
responsibility for Roy's death
ultimately lies with him in the manner
of death yes I marked that as suicide
okay and it was also a box that you
could have marked a homicide correct in
order to be convicted on the
manslaughter charge the judge would have
to agree that Carter's words caused
Roy's death but remember she was 35
miles away
unfortunately Massachusetts is one of
the only 11 states without a law that's
making it a crime to encourage a suicide
that's what she probably should have
been charged with rather than this
involuntary manslaughter just seems so
cruel I can't imagine the attention she
was trying to seek I have to tell you I
had a very as a parent a very difficult
time sitting in court you feel for both
but the amount of text and there were
times when he would say I don't think I
can do this
I think you should show what's gonna
happen today I could all in today the
the state rested the defense will
actually ask the judge to find her not
guilty saying that the state didn't
present enough evidence and that could
happen otherwise then the defense will
present this very odd defense called
intoxication by it antidepressant very
sad story Thank You Aaron